bitte was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video portals
waren jetzt mit der stimme gegen vorher
nach oben liegt noch von bingens ihr
silvester so deswegen habe ich viel rum
geschrieben okay wie gesagt ich hoffe
euch geht's gut
ihr seid alle super in das neue jahr
gekommen ich schon glaube ich auch wenn
es natürlich dieses jahr ein bisschen
anders war
aber egal wir haben einfach schon 2021
ich erinnere mich noch vor einer
grundschule immer so dass jahr dahin
geschrieben hat so 07 oder so und jetzt
einmal schon hoffen dass jetzt alles
besser wird und wir starten direkt war
mit einem geilen video und zwar ich
werde wirklich anderen gefragt alex
würden machst du keine videos mehr
machen mal wieder wurst von ruhig und
ich vermisse deine videos dazu
vielleicht ganz kurz ich hab ja sehr
viele videos gemacht und ich habe selber
gemerkt so zum ende hin es wurde mal so
irgendwie auf zwang wieder an rich video
und auch mit sachen die gar nicht
unbedingt geil und interessant waren
dachte mir lass das erstmal seien noch
andere sachen bis es irgendwann wirklich
wieder sachen gibt es sich lohnt auch
ein video zu machen und das ist jetzt so
weit also ich habe vor zwei wochen ein
iphone 12 fake bestellt und ich dachte
mir das könnte sich mal wieder lohnt da
reinzuschauen umzuschauen okay ist das
ein guter fällt wie sieht das aus wie
haben iphone elf fei gab werth ein
iphone ach ich hatte schon so viele
apple fans von will deswegen hoffe ich
dass es heute mal wieder interessant
wird und es sich lohnt ein video dazu zu
machen
wir haben hier den fake sieht echt gut
aus oder nein ich war es das hier ist
ein originales iphone 12 ja das habe ich
nämlich gekauft letztens und das sollte
noch verlost werden
ich habe im ganzen letzten mal ist in
jedem video was verlust fast und wir
haben immer noch sachen die ich verlosen
kann deswegen das einfach noch ein
bisschen weiter geht und heute ist dann
einfach mal dieses iphone 12 dran mehr
eines gerät ich glaube das hat 900 euro
kostet oder so und ich brauche das auch
für das heutige video um das vielleicht
so ein bisschen mit dem fake iphone zu
vergleichen wir machen das man kurz
deswegen auf ich hoffe das ist nicht
zustimmen werde er das oder die die das
dann gewinnt ist ja egal wie ihr habt
gesehen hier originales frisch
eingepackt des iphone 12 in der farbe
weiß war schön alter ich muss sagen ich
bin wirklich ein richtiger fan vom
iphone 12 ich finde das ultra geil dass
es wieder so kantig ist wie damals so
iphone 5
das war mein erstes iphone und geiles
teil also ich stelle das mal ganz kurz
ein weil wir das halt brauchen um das
vielleicht ein bisschen zu vergleichen
wenigstens wobei ich muss auch dazu
sagen es gab bayerisch irgendwie nur
iphone 12 pro max fakes und nicht vom
ganz normalen iphone 12 warum auch immer
also das ist ein iphone 12 pro max fake
lehnen wir uns auch mal ganz kurz
anschauen werden hier können wir das
ganze sehen telefonie 12 promax neues
smartphone also das heißt natürlich
nicht iphone 12 pro max ist ganz klar
das dürfen die nicht mehr das war glaube
ich auch mal anders da haben die
bayerisch absolut keinen kick gegeben
aber es hat sich geändert aber man kann
natürlich direkt sehen um welches iphone
es sich hier handeln soll
ja max wir haben hier einfach vier
kameras als ich das gesehen habe dachte
ich so hat apple jetzt wirklich schon
vier kameras installiert und dann habe
ich gemerkt okay nein bei dem originalen
sind weiterhin nur drei ich habe absolut
keine ahnung warum hier vier sind es
sieht halt krass aus so aber irgendwie
auch ein bisschen too much das ganze hat
108 euro gekostet hat jetzt nicht so die
besten bewertungen deswegen gehe ich
auch einfach mal davon aus dass wird ein
flop wobei hier steht useful kneis
looking practical i'm very happy mit
meiner frau denkt jurist ziemlich
schnell angekommen
bis jetzt nur gute gedanken gute apps
und sogar leisten
ich muss halt wirklich immer sagen das
habe ich schon so oft gesagt ich habe
keine ahnung welche menschen sich so ein
handy bestellen und dann halt so sagen
wollen er ich habe jetzt ein originales
iphone hier aber gut jedem das seine
und ja das hier sind doch noch weitere
fotos wobei ich hier sagen muss wie
sieht es dann irgendwie schauen nicht
mehr so ganz aus wien iphone
na ja ach so hier stehen noch ein paar
infos dazu iphone ii 12 pro max da kommt
man schon immer fast durcheinander 16
megapixel frontkamera hd-kamera power
für performance android 10.08 dual sim
karte h ach so das habe ich noch gar
nicht gesagt wie ihr das iphone 12
gewinnen könnt also eine person kann es
logischerweise nur gewinnen einfach
irgendeinen kommentar schreiben und den
kanal alex wie abonnieren das ist ganz
wichtig da würde ich mich super dollar
freuen
und dann werde ich in circa einer woche
oder so das ganze auflösen
auf meinem instagram profil da heisst
alex wie in der story
werde ich das dann mit so einem
zufallsgenerator machen wie es bisher
auch bei den ganzen sachen gemacht habe
die gewinne werden übrigens jetzt morgen
alle verschickt zumindest die die schon
ausgelost wurden wobei das eigentlich
fast alle sind ich habe es nicht
geschafft und wegen corona wollte ich
auch nicht immer zur post laufen ich
hoffe das könnt ihr verstehen hier haben
wir das iphone 12 wunderbar so wie man
es kennt auf jeden fall also hier die
ganzen apps und jetzt kommen wir hier
mal zu meinem 12 pro match von wish ich
bin ultra gespannt und wir werden mal
schauen
ich kann mich sehr gut an ein iphone 11
glaube ich erinnern dass ich bei uns
bestellen was schon ziemlich nah an das
original heran kam zumindest vom design
her das war glaube ich in dem video ich
habe alle apple-geräte bayerisch
bestellt also das müsste aber auch schon
so ein halbes jahr her seien hier steht
einfach direkt war auf quad kamera wobei
ich mir sicher bin dass die absolut
fähiges wetten im endeffekt gibt es nur
eine kamera das werden wir gleich mal
checken wir machen das ganze mal auf ok
alter ja so ist es ein gepackt ich muss
sagen ist nicht mein geschmack wenn man
das jetzt hier so sieht dieses dieses
grün wobei ich das wahrscheinlich auch
selber ausgewählt habt das gibt es
wahrscheinlich auch noch in anderen
farben und hier haben wir dann diese
vier herdplatten krasse ich bin gespannt
werden wir gleich mal abstecken
hier kann ich jetzt noch die folie
abziehen ach so leute das ist neu es ist
schon direkt zum panzerglas drauf okay
machen wir das hier mal ab ihr könnt
sehen er ist schon ziemlich groß wobei
das iphone 12 pro max auch sehr sehr
groß ist ich hatte schon mal eins in der
hand ich habe jetzt wie gesagt leider
kein ziel und ja ansonsten ist da halt
eigentlich ich muss schon sagen sie auf
den ersten eindruck hat dass bis auf
diese kameras jetzt eigentlich gar keine
ähnlichkeit aber gut ich mache es nur an
wir hatten ja auch schon mal ein star
war wirklich hinten im apple logo drauf
da musstest du die auch wenn ich das
schon wieder sehen
da musst du hier hinten so eine folie
abziehen damit es der zoll nicht merkt
oder so und dann ist hier so ein apple
logo erschienen
welcome das kenne ich wunderschön
wunderbar war also mehr schmerzt es
gerade schon ein bisschen dass sich
hierfür wirklich 100 euro bezahlt hat
android ist das ding wir haben hier ein
android system ios aber
das sollte auch jedem von euch da jetzt
hier auf dieses video geklickt hat
wahrscheinlich klar gewesen sein und das
handy ist auch schon hochgefahren wir
mussten hier wirklich gar nichts selber
einrichten
die krawatte fakt ok kleinen moment wir
entsperren weil das iphone 12 so sieht
das jetzt hier jeweils aus ihr könnt
schon sehen absolut identisch das tut
mir jetzt auch echt ein bisschen leid
weil ich habe gedacht ich kann euch hier
wirklich ein iphone 12 zeigen was
einigermaßen gut gefällt ist
wir gehen man hier auf die kamera drauf
und sehen die kamera ist nicht gut was
ich aber direkt mal sagen muss die
kamera ist noch so aufgebaut wie es
damals war
beim iphone 4 mit dieser rolle also
frontkamera absolut müll und hier die
innen kamera ja also ist okay würde ich
einfach mal sagen jetzt wollte ich nur
mal folgenden test machen und zwar hier
wurde jetzt mit der rasse wir haben noch
gar nicht geschaut was ist noch dabei
wunderbare kopfhörer ja der neueste
schrei acht gast wir haben aber sogar ja
immerhin auch momentan wir ernähren uns
jetzt so langsam jedoch eine mai von 12
an
wir haben hier noch eine hülle dabei und
dann haben wir hier auch diese nadel um
die sim-karte ihre zu machen sagt jetzt
ist es wieder ausgegangen weil ich jetzt
dieses sim kartenfach rausgezogen habe
ist das ganze handy ausgegangen krasse
neue technik ach so genau hier bin ich
stehen geblieben wir haben hier
tatsächlich ein usb auf usb kabel
das ist wirklich der neueste schrei das
hätte ich jetzt auf den ersten eindruck
wirklich nicht für nötig gehalten jetzt
ist es schon wieder ausgegangen er jetzt
nicht mehr alltag so gehen wir mal ganz
kurz in die einstellungen und hier
werden wir jetzt angezeigt halte ich
fest leute vorm tod in memory sage und
schreibe zwei gigabyte dh ihr könnt
unendlich viele fotos mit diesem gerät
schießen der speicher wird einfach nicht
voll werden ich meine zwei gigabyte
stellt euch das mal vor zwei gigabyte
hatte ich auf meinem htc damals das
müsst ihr so 2010 gewesen sein schon
also das ist wirklich ein absoluter witz
wobei was man dann wieder
gegenargumenten können wir haben hier
wirklich einen full screen die unten
auch mit dem home button auf dem
bildschirm drauf also der bildschirm ist
komplett ausgefüllt und jetzt wollte ich
aber mal kurz in die kamera hochnehmen
passt auf ich wette
wenn ich jetzt ihr könnt das sehen wenn
ich jetzt hier oben links auf die kamera
halte so als ich jetzt meinen finger
drauf jetzt liegt man nichts so hier
jetzt wähle ich einfach mal die kamera 1
weiter unten und ihr könnt sehen
man sieht ja alles jetzt will ich mal
die daneben wo man sieht immer noch
alles und jetzt wenig die oben und
stelle fest man sieht immer noch alles
das heißt diese drei kameralinsen sind
absolut fähig wird jetzt mal
interessieren wie das dann aussieht kann
man das irgendwie da musste ich jetzt
eigentlich mal draufhauen hey leute
passen auf ich habe jetzt einen plan und
zwar glaube ich das ist komplett alles
also das ist einfach nur drauf gelegt an
sich will ich jetzt nämlich gar nicht
auch unnötig weiter auf irgendwelche
features von diesen dingen eingehen
ich glaube das hat nicht mal face id
also wir hatten bei dem wifi von 11 was
ich damals hatte casey die mit buy bei
dem hier nicht mehr
ich verstehe echt nicht was die chinesen
da machen eigentlich könnte man ja
erwarten dass sie sich steigern und es
immer besser wird aber das hier ist
wirklich scheiße
[Musik]
hh guck mal hier kommt schon hoch so
vorsichtig ich will jetzt nicht in
meinen finger schneiden es ist einfach
nur eine kameralinse riehl und der rest
einfach so drauf gelegt
da sieht man mal wie weit gekommen ist
irgendwelche firmen machen einfach so
kameralinsen drauf damit krasser
aussieht und anscheinend kaufen es leute
deswegen abkommen dann kann ich auch
eigentlich mal alles abnehmen
so sieht das darunter aus aber es ist
sogar noch an auf jeden fall im großen
und ganzen ich habs jetzt getestet ich
kann es keinem von euch empfehlen also
bestellt euch bitte bayerisch kein fake
iphone 12 das ist der grösste müll das
geld könnt ihr dann lieber in ein
vernünftiges android geräte gibt es ja
auch genug gerät für 120 130 euro die
sind absolut in ordnung aber sowas hier
das ist wirklich so scheiße ist und so
wenig an ein originales iphone 12 heran
kommt hätte ich nicht gedacht also das
hatten wir auch noch nie und das tut mir
wirklich ein bisschen leid für alle die
jetzt hier drauf geklickt haben und sich
da was besseres oder interessanteres
erhofft hatten trotzdem könnte ja dieses
iphone 12 gewinnen ich wünsche euch viel
glück und wir sehen uns dann übermorgen
wieder gibt es ein neues video apotheker
in den kanal daumen nach oben wäre cool
wenn die ideen für weitere videos oder
wenn irgendwas gesehen habe
was ich eurer meinung nach nun zu
bestellen könnte es mir gern bei
instagram schicken das war es von mir
danke fürs zuschauen haut rein leute